the Joe Rogan experience that is a
really strange thing though that if you
can contain it somehow an incredibly
strong pipe yes it won't freeze yes it
will freeze what is a temperature
variant is there a number well that's
why that's why pipes don't freeze when
it just hits 30 degrees outside that's
not when you hear it it freezes when it
gets really low when it crack and yeah
and then it'll break the copper like
it's paper and tear it like it's like
it's nothing now on the flip side of
that try this at home take an ice cube
that's like at 30 degrees okay how would
you measure that pull out an ice cube
and just because there'll be at near
zero Fahrenheit if you if you have a
good freezer just pull out and leave it
on the counter put put it on a wooden
cutting board okay and just let it sit
there for like ten minutes and it's
temperature will come up there'll be a
point where it hasn't melted yet but you
can take it and squeeze the ice cube and
you can force it to melt by squeezing it
because you're forcing it into a smaller
volume that it currently contains and
the only way you can accomplish that is
if the ice turns to water then it will
occupy a smaller volume so the act of
squeezing ice can actually melt it so if
you had some sort of a pipe that could
physically constrict like something that
had threads it in there could wind down
to a smaller size you could stick a
cylinder of ice in it and you could
slowly crank
oh yeah yes yes it would melt yes you
can melt if you had some machine that
squeezed ice yeah and the colder the ice
is the heart this the the more you'd
that the harder it would be for you to
squeeze it to accomplish that so it's
sort of fun with ice in fact you know
what else you can do this is a harder
experiment to do if you take us a mesh
like a screen mesh that's to be sort of
wider openings then a screen door would
so what would this be like a fence like
a chain-link fence and behold
horizontally and get a big block of ice
and just place it on top a block of ice
is heavy what will happen is the ice the
weight of the ice will melt the ice in
the contact points of the chain itself
because it's feeling that pressure
to squeeze it into a smaller volume but
by the time it melts the ice has now
passed through the grate and it will
refreeze on the other side so you can
actually pass a block of ice through a
chain-link fence vertically just by
pushing it yeah it's pretty it's pretty
cool it's a slow experiment but it's
real long I mean depends on the
temperature the ice and how and how and
how much it weighs because the pressure
is what this is why this way you can ice
skate why can you skate on ice because
the edge of the blade is very high
pressure on the ice and it's melting a
bead of order you're actually gliding on
water when you're skating you're not
skating on slippery ice really yes I
thought you were just cutting the ice
with the blade well so the blade have
you ever seen a sharpened blade it's not
just flat there's actually a concave
cross-section to it so each edge the
left edge and the right edge is is
basically a knife edge mm-hmm okay not
quite as sharp as a knife but it's you
can feel how it's it's sharp so that
when you lean on that edge either your
inner edge or outer edge your entire
body weight is being held up on this on
a very narrow surface area of the blade
so the pressure is extreme it's like you
know thousand pounds per square inch you
don't weigh a thousand pounds but you're
not skating on a square inch right so
you you do the math on that and what you
can have is a you you will skate and
you're actually what makes it so
slippery on ice skates is because you're
moving on a bead of water that freezes
right behind you as you go past it dude
yeah so it's possible for ice to be so
cold you can't really skate on it
because even that pressure is not enough
to melt it how cool would it have to be
that I last I did a calculation was
really cold like tens of degrees below
zero
[Applause]